um
good morning uh good afternoon and good
evening to everyone who just joined us
for another instance of the
workshop on program synthesis which is
part of a
siemens institute program on
theoretical foundations of computer
systems
we will have four presenters today
three longer talks and one shorter
poster style presentation we'll start
with
todd milstein from ucla
todd is a professor at ucla got his phd
at the university of washington uh his
advisor was
craig chambers todd worked on huge range
of
problems in programming languages from
language design
optimizations and other implementations
to
predicate abstractions and other aspects
of program analysis
uh language is for various domains and
today he'll talk about
uh inference of invariance which you
could
think of as one branch of program
synthesis
with that todd thank you for joining us
today we look forward to the talk
oh great thanks ross for having me okay
so you can see the screen
everything's good okay great so um yeah
i'm going to talk about some recent work
uh on inferring representation of
marriage i'll tell you what that is but
i wanted to kind of back up a little bit
first and give kind of some of the
bigger picture so
um you know if you look today at where
uh some of the most exciting i think
interesting work on
getting strong guarantees for real
systems is it's
in the context of people using these
interactive proof assistants for example
[ __ ] and isabel
where you know the human is kind of
directing things and providing
the program and in an interactive way
and the specification
and kind of writes these proof scripts
which use forms of automation that the
proof of system provides and the proof
of system is giving a bunch of things
it's giving kind of bookkeeping telling
you where you are in your proof and what
subgoals you have remaining and it
has this these language of tactics where
you can write little proof automation
scripts
and it's giving you feedback on errors
and people have done real things with
with these tools uh
probably the most notable one is the
comp cert verified c compiler
and there's been others over the years
os micro kernel
verified web browser and the bottom line
is that this stuff actually works a good
example of this is that you know there
was this
there's been a lot of work on tools for
finding bugs and compilers
c smith is one prominent example and in
their paper from 2011 they said
you know we found bugs in all these c
compilers concert's the only compiler we
tested for which we can't find
wrong code errors and they say this is
not for lack of trying we devoted about
six cpu years to the task so
actually going through this effort of
having approval guarantees actually
means something
um but the problem of course is that
it's crazy expensive
um and so you know uh this is from the
the paper on the os micro the verified
os micro kernel
seo for uh so the spec they wrote took
about four person months that's not
that bad it took about two years to
write the actual
operating system implementation then
they wrote in haskell then they
converted to c that took a little bit of
time but not very much
but the proof cost was 20 person years
so um
so so clearly there's an issue here
which is that
you know this stuff is really promising
and exciting i think but really just
too too much time and effort involved to
use this
and so you can ask well why is that and
there could be many reasons but one
observation that i'll make is that
the kind of proof automation that these
tools provide today is largely what i'll
call
local automation meaning uh you know
within a single lemma or a single
theorem so they help you you say i want
to prove this lemma
and the tool will kind of do small proof
automation within there to help you
prove that level
but what i'll argue is that what we're
missing is
automation for what i'll call the larger
scale proof architecture
so if you think about it when you give
just like with a program if you give a
pro
specification it's not just the end end
specification that matters you have to
then decompose it into lemmas for
individual modules
uh you know help those lemmas might need
other helper lemmas lemmas typically
need to be strengthened so that they
can be proven by induction they're
module-wide or system-wide inductive
invariants
so the whole structure the whole
architecture of the proof is something
that right now the human has to come up
with
on their own uh they have to kind of
come up with the whole structure and say
these are the limits i want to prove and
then
within each of those lemmas the proof of
system will help them
and so the observation is that these are
all program synthesis tasks specifically
these are these are forms of invariant
so finding the right helper lemons
finding the right strengthening for a
lemma
finding the right inductive invariance
these these are forms of synthesis
and so um and so
the argument is that synthesis really
can be at the heart of what can make
these kinds of interactive program
development and verification systems
more practical
um and so this is what i've been doing
in part for the last five plus years is
forms of automated
invariant inference um so that's kind of
just
that's sort of the bigger picture um and
by the way if there are questions or
comments throughout just feel free so a
couple years ago i was on i was on
sabbatical at princeton
and i i gave a talk about uh some of the
work we had done on invariant imprints
and um dave walker my host said oh
how about you know could you do this for
representation americans for data
structures and he was teaching
representation and variants in his
uh class undergraduate class and
so we started this project and um that's
what i'm going to tell you about
today so uh so anders miltner was
one of dave's phd students uh he's now a
postdoc at ut
austin and sascha patty was my phd
student who also did
the prior work that that i was involved
in on automated invariant inference
that was his dissertation work and he's
now in amazon at the
automated reasoning group okay
um so a representation
and i'll tell you what it is more
specifically but basically this is about
trying to prove
that a data structure implementation
meets the specification of the data
structure
so here's a simple kind of interface for
it
for it for an integer sets sets of
integers
um so this is using sort of a camel
style or functional style
so the interface for a set is it's some
abstract type t
uh that has an empty value representing
the empty set
and has different operations like insert
delete lookup
and then there's a specification and
this isn't a full specification but you
could do a full specification but just
just for example
you might want to prove that you know
looking up anything in the empty empty
set gives you false
and looking up something after you've
inserted it
is always true and looking up something
after you've all after you've deleted it
is always false
so now here's an implementation again in
ocam
of this set and here what i'm doing
internally is internally i'm using an
integer list
as my representation of the integer set
and then i implement all the operations
in terms of integer lists
and so um that's fine
and now we can go ahead and and you
could do this in cocktail [ __ ] has a
has a has a language that's very much
like a camel so i could write all this
up in [ __ ] and then i could try to prove
these things
and if i do that um i'll find that yes i
can prove that for example looking up
something empty
always returns false because empty is
the empty list and looking up and empty
returns false so that's fine
and if you think about it for a second
you can prove that the insert property
holds as well
but if you try to prove the delete
property um that deleting something
returns and then looking it up returns
false um
if you just directly try to prove it you
won't be able to prove it in caulk or in
any
interactive proof assistant you'll get
stuck uh one
poor thing about those tools is that you
know you won't get a counter example
you'll just get stuck trying to prove
the thing
but i'll tell you a counter example
here's a counter example if if i give an
input list
zero that's this list zero zero and i
delete zero
then if you look at what this thing does
it only deletes the first occurrence of
something
so it'll it'll actually leave you with
the list zero remaining and
so that means that looking up zero and
that thing will still return true
so so um that's why i won't be able to
prove this but of course
in fact this code is correct that's not
a valid counter example
um even though i won't be able to prove
it and so
why is it not about a valid counter
encounter example well for kind of a
standard reason but
in the context of data structure
implementation it's like this there's a
set of all integer lists
but there's a subset of all integer
lists that are actually reachable
actually constructable through the
module interface
um and in fact that one is not
constructable through the module
interface because the module is
carefully ensuring this
variant that the list it's creating have
no duplicates
um and that's kind of implicit but
insert for example is doing that because
it's not adding something
unless if it's already in the list and
so on
and so
yeah so zero zero is kind of outside of
the set of actual reachable integer
lists that represent
sets and so
this leads to kind of the standard style
for proving that a data structure
implementation meets its interface
which is to identify an invariant call
it the representation invariant
it's some predicate on the set of
integer lists and it has to have
two properties one is that it has to
imply the specification
so it has to be stronger than the
specification
and the other is that it has to
be weaker than the set of all reachable
integer lists so it has to include the
set of all reachable energy lists or
another way to say that it has to be
inductive
meaning it has to be preserved by all
the module operations
and so if you can identify in such an
invariant
and you can prove that it implies the
spec and it's inductive
then you're done then you've proven that
you're you're that your module meets the
spec
and so yeah and so in our case
um in this particular example here's an
inductive invariant that works
uh it's a it's written as a recursive
function let's say a predicate that says
there's no duplicates
and so um it
if i claim that that's my representation
invariant then i have to prove two
things one is i have to prove that
um things
integer sets or integer lists that
represe that satisfy the invariant imply
the spec and that's going to be true
that happens to be true
like that 0 0 list is no longer
applicable because it doesn't satisfy
the invariant so we don't have to
consider it
um and we have to prove that it's
inductive and you do that just kind of
module operation by module operation so
i can prove that empty has no duplicates
because empty is just the empty list
for insert you have to prove in the
normal inductive way that if
your if insert is given it as a list
that satisfies the invariant then it
will
produce a list that satisfies the
invariant and i can go through and prove
all these
and so that's how i that's how improved
that's how you would manually prove that
this integer list satisfies its set
specification that the module
satisfies the set specification
and this is how things are done so like
there's a book you know andrew pell has
this book on verified functional
algorithms it's full of
data structures implemented in caulk
that are proven correct
um using this way but again the human
has to figure out
the programmer the tools the automation
doesn't help you at all with this you
have to come up with the inductive
invariant the representational variant
um you know the
the automation will help you prove these
two things but you have to come up with
the invert yourself and the invariant
has to be you know strong enough
but not too strong and you know not too
weak and if you get that wrong then
you're on your own to kind of go and fix
that and whatever so this is sort of an
opportunity
for automation to and in particular
forms of program synthesis to say can we
help people
to synthesize valid sufficient
representation of variants
to prove that their data structures are
correct so the quick question
before you go on to the i assume the
core of the
talk uh can you comment on the
connection between
um sort of the hierarchy that we see
right and
proving full versus partial correctness
of a data structure right
so sometimes we just want to prove
something that does not guarantee full
correctness right we omit sum property
is it is there a connection between say
the reachable
and the invariant and the less
satisfying specification
not being the same set but being sort of
strict subsets of each other and
proving full correctness or
these two things are completely
orthogonal from each other
um so let me
give an answer and see if that's what
you're asking um there there's a well
the way i think about it so the the
invariant
the the invariant that you need
there can be many invariants that work
and the invert you need just has to
satisfy these properties so if the spec
is weaker then
the invariant can be weaker so so for
example um
so definitely there's nothing that
requires this to be a full spec like so
as a simple example let's say that all i
cared about is this very first property
and i didn't care about the other
properties then in fact my
representation event could just be true
because there's i don't need to know
anything more about the list module
other than what's already
uh then i don't even know anything more
about the list module than what's
already here there's no other invariance
that i need to depend on
in order to prove that so even though
the module does maintain a much stronger
invariant than true true would be a
sufficient invariant
just to prove that spec and so um
depending on and so this happened in our
in our experiments too depending on what
spec you're trying to prove you you need
us you might
you know with a weaker spec you won't
you might need essentially no
like a true representation variant or a
very weak representation
but the stronger properties you want to
prove may need more
stronger representation of merits in
order to justify them in order to prove
them
so that makes sense now in your specific
case it seems that you are
proving full correctness right
of the three properties right
technically not because you'd also have
to show that
i mean there are a couple of things
missing here but uh like
you like you have the positive case of
insert that if you insert something
and then look it up then that's fine
you'd also need a case that says if you
insert something and then you look up
some j that's not i then
then it's equivalent to uh looking up uh
in the old set you know looking up j in
the old set so there's a couple of
things missing here but
maybe that's but i don't know if that
relates to your question or not i think
that was essentially my question i could
ask more about let's let's go on
it was very useful thank you yeah so the
bottom line is that the
you know kind of like likes to say with
a loop invariant too like the the you
know the loop invariant that you need to
prove some
property depends on the post condition
that you're trying to prove the property
you're trying to prove so
the invariant is some you know internal
thing just for the proof and so it's
how strong it needs to be depends on how
strong the spec is and so yeah that's
that's the main point
okay right
so what we've done is we've built this
algorithm and associated tool called
hanoi that takes these three things your
interface and your implementation and
your spec
and it spits out a representation of it
and of course it's not quite magic like
that because it's solving a really hard
problem and so
um we'll see that there's some some you
know
there's some limitations on on on it but
um this is kind of the goal
we set ourselves is can we can we
generate these
sufficient representation variants um
just given these three things
okay and so what we did was we created
this
data-driven algorithm for doing that we
formalized it and proved some properties
about it that i'll tell you about we
implemented it and we've evaluated it on
a bunch of
[ __ ] data structures
so the algorithm is a data-driven
algorithm um
just like other data-driven algorithms
for for synthesis and so it
it actually combines synthesis and
verification it uses then
two black box tools a synthesizer and
verifier this is a very standard setup
so you the way we're going to do things
is you've got we assume we've got a
synthesizer and it can be
we we're not we're not innovating there
we're just given a synthesizer and what
it does is
given input output examples it generates
a program that meets those examples and
in this case our programs are going to
be predicates they're going to be in
variance
and then that's a candidate invariant
then the verifier will check it and say
either yes and we're done or no and
here's a counter example
and so that becomes a new example for
the synthesizer
and so here's how this works let's say
we have a bunch of positive and negative
examples
and we'll start out with no no no
examples um
in the beginning but at some point we
have some so in our case they're
positive and negative examples examples
whose output is true and examples
output is false that's that's those are
the examples for the synthesizer
um we generate some invariant
the first thing we can do is check does
this invariant imply the specification
that was
that was one of the things we have to
check
um so like in our case we can check in
our example we could check whether now
the invariant implies the spec
if that's true if that's valid we'll
move on but if that's not valid
the thing you have to do is figure out
okay well this counterexample you'll get
back
is that a new positive example or is
that a new negative example and
in this case it's pretty easy to see
that it's a new negative example why
because
something that violates this condition
is is an in is it is a list an integer
list in our case that satisfies the
invariant or violates the spec
and so if it satisfies the invariable
violence and spec if the spec is
actually true then that means that the
the invariant is too weak it's including
this integer so that it shouldn't be
including
so we should treat that set as a new
negative example and that will force us
to generate a stronger invariant the
next time around
that doesn't include that example
so that's fine and then you want to
check then you need to check
you know is that invariant inductive and
this is where the more interesting thing
happens if that's valid then you're done
but
if it's not valid the real hard part
about kind of doing
uh data-driven invariant inference for
inductive invariance is that
it's it's not clear when you get a
counter example to inductiveness whether
you should treat that as a positive or a
negative example
um and let me show you why that is so
here's a really bad candidate invariant
uh which is that the length of the list
is less than two
but let's i'm just using that as an
example let's say at some point in our
algorithm
um you say the candidate invariant the
candidate invariant is that the length
of the list is less than two
that holds for the empty list when we
try to prove that that's inductive
for the insert operation what we'll find
is that
it's not and here's a counter example
you know i can give a list
whose length is less than two like the
list containing one but after i insert i
get something whose length is equal to
two and so that violates the invariant
the the fundamental issue is that there
are two ways to resolve this counter
example so what a counter example to
inductiveness is it's
it's a pair it's a pair of a pre-state
that satisfies the invariant and a
post-state that
violates the invariant and so one way to
go is to say well i need to strengthen
the invariant to eliminate that
guy or the other way to go say no i need
to weaken the invariant
to include that guy and either one of
those would be a way to resolve that
counter example
but i don't a priori kind of know which
is the right way to go
and so that leads to kind of a
combinatorial explosion if i had to kind
of search for
you know search in both directions for
every inductiveness counter example
so the observation we make which is
quite simple is that
consider the special case when we happen
to know that this list one is actually
reachable it's actually a constructable
representation of a set in that case
then there's no choice because
if it's reachable then that means it
must be included in the environment and
if it's reachable then that means that
this guy is also reachable because we
can obtain it by calling insert on this
guy
and therefore the only thing to do that
therefore this is also a reachable
set representation and therefore the
only thing to do is to include it
in the invariant
and so
that leads us to define this notion of
of what we call visible inductiveness
which will say that an invariant is a
candidate invariant is visibly inductive
it's if it's inductive relative to
the known set of reachable values
so it's not necessarily fully inductive
but it's inductive relative to the
known set of reachable values and so
what we're going to do and i'll show you
this in a moment is that we're going to
carefully maintain
in our algorithm that all the positive
examples we're maintaining
are known to be reachable they're known
to be constructable through module
operations
and so what this lets us do is we can
check
visible inductiveness by checking
inductance relative to the current set
of positive examples
and so um when i go to check visible
inductiveness on insert
i'll check it just with respect to these
examples saying
if if s is one of those examples then
you know does the output satisfy the
invariant in this case we still get that
same counter example because the list
one is in our set
but now we know that the only thing to
do is to weaken because we know the list
one is reachable it's in our positive
examples
the only thing to do is to weaken and
include zero one
so i haven't really so let me show you
how we use that and
why that's useful um so what we're gonna
do now
is back to our algorithm
after we get to the point of ensuring
that the invariant is strong enough to
imply the spec we want to check
inductiveness
but we're not going to check
inductiveness right away we're going to
check visible inductiveness
and so what this is going to have the
effect of doing is kind of
forcing us to eagerly weaken it's
essentially saying let me deal with all
the forms of inductiveness that i
that i know i don't have to be
non-deterministic about that i know
has i know how to deal with let me let
me try to deal with those eagerly so
i'm gonna we can iteratively weaken
um until i'm visibly inductive
because i know that in those cases i
have to weaken and one way to think
about that conceptually is what we're
doing is we're saying we have some
frontier of known reachable things
and visible inductiveness is making sure
that that frontier
if you take any one step further from
that frontier like you insert or you
delete
you're still satisfying the invariant so
it's sort of checking one step
inductiveness
so we're gonna we're gonna weaken until
we're at least sort of one step
inductive
and then we'll check full inductive risk
now at that point we still have the
problem that you don't know when you get
a counter example whether to weaken or
strengthen
but given our algorithm there's actually
one thing we can do because
at this point because the invariant is
visibly inductive
any full inductance counter example will
have the effect that will have the
property that the pre-state
is not known to be reachable if it were
known to be reachable then this would be
a counter example to visible
so we can't we basically we can't weaken
here because that would violate our
invariant that all the positive things
are known to be reachable so the only
thing to do here
is to actually strengthen at this point
treat the pre-state as bad
that may turn out to be wrong because we
don't know whether the pre-state
is reachable or not but we'll correct
that um kind of the next time around
when we go and try to again check
visible inductors so
so what's happening is that the positive
examples are sort of maintaining true
positives really reachable things
and the negative examples are just
maintaining things that are negative
relative
to the current inductive and variant
candidate the current invariant
candidate they may or may not be really
negative
and we'll find that out as we go around
again and so in fact because of that
every time we weaken we have to actually
um you could maybe be smarter about this
but we just completely empty out the
negative examples because
again the negative examples aren't
necessarily true negatives they're just
negative relative to
a current candidate invariant
and so this is the idea so basically
strengthen to the spec
you weaken to be sort of one step
inductive
uh and then you treat the rest the other
inductiveness failures as negative but
but they are correctable in in the next
time around
oh the quick question i assume you
considered just
asking a reachability query on a on a
counter example right
and rejected that idea
is it because it's so hard to solve in
general
um that's a good question i yeah i don't
know
i mean so how it i guess that's a good
that's something you could consider
i guess if the modulus simple enough you
mean just sort of explore up to some
up to some boundary or like just try to
run run the module or simulate the
module up to some
some bound of interactions um i guess
you could do that
um i mean in some sense what the
algorithm is doing is iteratively doing
that
that frontier exploration anyway so in
some sense
um that's what's happening but yeah
actually i mean maybe that could be
that that could be a way to go you could
just eagerly try to search for
a reachable uh search for it being
reachable
um so can you recap for us how deep is
that backtracking so
if you follow that um outermost loop
right very check full inductiveness
you assume it's a negative example
now at that point you flush the negative
example
from upper left right
so at this point we add a negative
example and we don't we don't change
anything we just add a negative example
but what's going to happen is
let's say i put something in the
negatives that actually
should be should be reachable um then
eventually
when i check visible inductiveness i'll
actually
i'll actually catch that i'll catch i'll
see that basically
um i'll the v
in some sense what's happening is the
visible inductance check is
is in expanding our reachable frontier
and so you could do what you suggested
which is eagerly
be reachable but but the visual energy
is essentially eagerly expanded
is sort of doing the one-step expansion
of the frontier of known reachable
things
and so what happens there it's not
really shown here but if we expand the
frontier and that includes something
that's
currently in our negative set then we
know that that's really a positive and
should be moved to the positives
and by emptying out the negatives when
we do that we kind of
avoid having a conflict like a false
conflict where something is considered
both positive and negative
i see but that might take several single
step expansions right
seen true okay right maybe the reason
that it worked okay is because counter
examples tend to be small
it depends on how you get counter
examples but if you get you know if
you're going to get a counter example
that's
size 20 list then you'd be you'd be in
trouble but if you're going to get small
counter examples then maybe this works
okay so
yeah get it there is a question in chat
from karum
are the synthesized invariants always
universally quantified
or other scenarios in which universally
quantified invariants
are insufficient uh that's a good
question
um so the the theory works more
generally but our
our tool only supports sort of
universally our implementation only
supports
being universally quantified at the
front so yeah definitely if you
uh there you know if you for many you
know there are natural examples where
you say for all this there exists a y
such that whatever so those things you
know fit in the theory of how to
of representation and variance and i
think this algorithm nothing in this
algorithm depends on being universally
quantified just at this level of
abstraction
but our implementation only supports um
you know sort of universally qualified
at the front yeah
thank you toad uh great thanks
so um so that's kind of the algorithm at
a high level
what we've done is we have this kind of
type theoretic formalization where we
formalize this
in the traditional style for modules
where a
module type or a module interface is an
existential type where it's existential
over this
the unknown implementation type of the
module so that's like the t
in our example that's the set type alpha
and then that's the type of the module
itself the set the set of operations
that the module supports
and the implementation is a pair of a
concrete implementation type for alpha
that would be integer list in our
example
and then the actual module value
and we'll see the benefit of this in a
minute but so
we can formalize our problem then it's
giving given such an interface and given
such a module and given a specification
um which yes is is actually in our
formalization
uh universally quantified at the front
then
um we're trying to find a representation
invariant
a sufficient representation variant
which we denote this way and
the the key thing in our formalism is
that we need this notion of
um well we need full inductiveness and
we also need this notion of
visible inductance so what we've done is
developed this type index logical
relation which kind of generalizes both
of them which we call conditional
inductance which you can read as saying
that
a value at a particular type
is conditionally inducted for q relative
to p so think of p as the pre-state
and q as the post state and so when
they're the same invariant like let's
say they're both i
then that's checking full inductiveness
but but but this could be something like
the set of reachable known things and
then this is i then that's our visible
inductance so this is a more general
form of that for conditional inductance
conditional relative to a pre-state p
for acute state opposed to q um
you don't have to read all these things
but the the key advantage of
using the type theoretic approach is
that
we can now easily lift things to an
arbitrary uh
arbitrary module type so here we're
showing how to deal with um
pairs which can lift to arbitrary
twofolds here we're showing how to deal
with
functions and for example you have the
contravariance on the argument and the
cova
and the covariance on the result so what
this means is that for example one thing
i didn't show
is like for example sets let's say all
the examples in the set that i showed
you
have a single element of the actual
abstract type as an argument like insert
delete
but there are things like union on sets
or intersection on sets which take two
sets
and return a set and so this tells you
sort of how to lift
lift the algorithm directly to
situations like that where you actually
where you have functions for example
that take two sets as an argument
and return a set and and and here we're
lift and here we're showing how do you
get counter examples when when it's not
valid
and again how do you get counter
examples from pairs how do you get
counter examples from functions and
things like that
so in fact the formalism is limited to
first order
functions but the implementation
actually also handles higher order
functions so we can do we can
we can get counter examples from higher
order we can
we can this actually is a sound notion
of what it means for a higher order code
to be conditionally inductive but then
uh this only models how to get counter
examples from first order code but in
the implementation we actually handle
higher order code as well so
you can do some form of high order
contract checking to actually get
counter examples
even to higher functions so you could
for example have a a set data type that
has a map operation
which is a higher order function on it
and you can and and this will show you
how to
how to check inductiveness of that and
how to get how to get inductive counter
examples
we probably have five minutes to the
okay and uh
you know we are now at 30 but but of
course there are questions so
i don't know what you want to cover in
the five minutes and then we'll have
more
questions i'm sure okay sure so yeah i i
can go pretty quickly so
um a couple of properties we have one is
soundness so here we're assuming that
the underlying verifier the algorithm is
parameterized by a verifier and
synthesizer
i assume the verifier and synthesizer
are sound and complete for normal
definitions of what that means
under those strong assumptions then we
can prove that hanoi is sound
if it generates an invariant then in
fact that's a valid representational
variant it's also
complete for a special case it's
complete
in the case when the implementation type
is finite
uh that is a pretty strong restriction
it's a restriction on the theory that
implementation supports
um you know data types that are that
have infinite number of values
but i would argue that even this is an
interesting result even when the
the type is finite because if you
remember what the algorithm is doing
it's kind of ping-ponging back and forth
between strengthening and weakening the
invariant and so
it's not obvious that it won't get stuck
in some kind of loop of strengthening
and weakening and so
what this shows is that at least for
this special case it will eventually
find an answer and in fact i don't know
of any prior
the prior inductive invariant algorithms
data-driven ones that have a
completeness result are really kind of
trivially complete because they just do
some kind of bottom-up enumeration or
something so
this is doing something a little bit
smarter it's kind of ping-ponging back
and forth between weakening and
strengthening
but we can still show this kind of
special case of completeness
so we implemented this with myth with it
which is an existing synthesizer that
synthesizes recursive functions
in functional programs and we used an
unsound verifier so we just did
enumerative testing
for verification of course that's
unsound
but the benefit is that it's fast and it
terminates and
um it sort of supports our use case
where we're not necessarily trying to
replace the prover we're trying to just
help the prover
um give suggestions so um
we took a bunch of benchmarks here's
really the bottom line is that
uh we ran it with a timeout of 30
minutes we were able to actually infer
22 invariants out of the 28 cases we
tried
um and all of the invariants were
actually sufficient representation
variants even though we were just using
kind of an integrative tester
um instead of a sound verifier
the key limitation was that the
underlying synthesizer can only generate
a single recursive function it can't
generate
functions that need helper functions and
also generate those helper functions and
so whenever we needed an invariant that
couldn't be written as a single
recursive function or at least couldn't
easily
uh that's that's sort of why we got
these six
failures uh you don't really have to
read this but
the key point that's interesting is that
when it succeeds it succeeds within a
couple of minutes
um when it otherwise it times out and
we're handling you know a bunch of real
data structures from the library sets
and binary trees binary search trees
cues priority queues things like that
i'll quickly talk about related work if
i have a minute or two
i think the closest related
work is other work on data driven and
variant inference
there's been prior work on data-driven
loop and variant inference including my
own prior work that's really a special
case of this setting you can think of
that a loop as a module
that has a single operation of type t
arrow t
from pre-state to post state that's it
um and so this is really kind of a more
general setting
um chc solvers or constraint horn clause
solvers
are in some ways more general than the
setting we're considering because you
can have multiple unknown invariants
that you're solving for
but and there have been some data-driven
approaches there but they've typically
only supported
arithmetic constraints they haven't
considered the kind of constraints
that we have on data structures
recursive data structures
um and also high order functions which
we handle
in our implementation don't fit into the
sort of chc framework
we've defined this notion of visible
inductiveness interestingly there's kind
of a dual notion
in the literature of conditional
inductiveness
that have been that's been using static
techniques for um
invariant inference where it kind of
goes backwards
so the idea is that if you know that the
post state in an inductiveness counter
example
leads to a bad state then you know the
pre-state also leads to a bad state and
therefore is also bad
and so that's kind of like a backwards
approach of what we're doing
um the forward approach that we're doing
is more natural in the data-driven
setting where we kind of have
um actual concrete examples that we're
running concrete tests that we're
running
and there's only one other work that i
know that's specifically on trying to
infer representation in variants
uh they do this for java code
but they kind of just have a fixed
language of predicates and the invariant
must be sort of a bullying combination
of those predicates and they don't have
any sort of guarantees as a result
on the on the resulting invariants um
sanji did you have a question uh i do
but i can wait for you to conclude and
then
i'll ask oh okay um
so yeah that's basically what i wanted
to say i think um
i've shown you this data-driven
inference technique for representation
variance and we
we introduced this notion of visible
inductiveness um
the type theoretical formalization is
useful in sort of lifting to arbitrary
modules
at least arbitrary in the formalization
arbitrary first order modules in the
implementation
including higher order modules um
and i told you a little bit about the
implementation evaluation and kind of
popping back up
what i want to say is that really
program synthesis can be a key enabling
technology for program verification
that's kind of the
idea here so we're synthesizing
invariants kind of links
synthesis to verification um in an
interesting way
so that's it thank you
thank you todd let's open the floor for
questions
uh sanjit i assume you wanna yeah
let me go ahead so thanks todd for an
excellent talk um
my question was about uh your other work
on saga solving lupine gen
um and i wanted to understand how the
approach used in loop and gen
relates if at all to the approach that
you presented today
you know what aspects are similar and
what's different
which is your approach to solving okay
yeah thanks
um so i don't know if you i had a little
trouble hearing i don't know what other
people did too but i'll repeat the
question so i think the question was
about
so we have prior work on on newfound
variant inference
we had a tool called lupimgen and we've
done
done a bunch of work on that over the
years and the question was how this
algorithm relates to that algorithm so
um there are a couple differences
one is that um
again loop invariant inference is a
special case where you know you have
you can think of it as a as a module
that has a single function for a single
loop it's just a single function of type
t
arrow t it takes a pre-state to a post
state and so we had to figure out how to
generalize
to you know things where you have
multiple like
you know of a function of type t times t
arrow t so you take two instances of the
type to the type
so generalizing to multiple counter
examples
for an arbitrary first order type
instead of just a loop was one thing
the other key difference in the actual
algorithm is that loop
looping gen actually uses this heuristic
where it actually it doesn't do this
invisible inductiveness thing it
actually does
it actually does heuristic strengthening
so what it does is more like
uh whoops it actually does something
that's kind of more like what
um what what these people do
so if we get an inductiveness failure
on some invariant i it will try to find
an i prime that it can conjoin the i
to strengthen the invariant and and and
then try to find an i double prime that
it can conjoin
so it kind of uses this heuristic of of
heuristic strengthening
and then it will if it over strengthens
it'll only find that out sort of at the
very end
and so what we realized was that
actually lupin gen sometimes fails
because of that because
it goes down the wrong path and it
heuristically strengthens and it's
already
on the wrong path but it's going to keep
strengthening and strengthening and
strengthening
until only much later it finds out that
it's wrong and so
the visible inductance thing that what
it does is it actually forces you to
kind of weaken
early and weaken early and so
in in lupine gem we were only weakening
at the very end when we found some kind
of contradiction between the pre-state
and some overly strengthened uh
invariant so i think this eager
weakening is actually really useful
because it kind of keeps you honest you
strengthen
and then you eagerly weaken and i think
that's a i think that that's more
generally useful beyond
this tool like it would be actually
useful to port that back to luke and jen
for example
okay thank you
thanks we have additional questions
well if not let's thank todd again thank
you
and um we have elizabeth here
elizabeth kudio